[Music]
big shout out to hellofresh with
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
so go to hellofresh.com
fury16 and use code fury16 for up to 16
free meals and 3 free gifts that's
hellofresh.com fury16 for up to 16 free
meals and 3 free gifts hellofresh
america's number one meal kit
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of rissa fury i'm so excited uh
i'm your host kelsey cook we're here at
the zodiac studios as part of moon tower
comedy festival in austin we're doing
some special episodes during the
festival and
i couldn't think of two better people to
have on together please give it up for
taylor tomlinson returning guest and
samurail yay
it's always just me
there's no studio audience but uh
i'm i'm so happy you guys are here you
are our first couple that we have had on
the show but taylor you are also our
first returning guest am i yes oh hell
yeah yes so you've got um you've got
some knowledge now yeah you know some of
my tricks yeah oh i i told him i was
like we will not win he asked me this
morning he goes has she ever lost and i
was like oh you're so cute no
not one sweet sweet man you sweet sweet
man she showed me footage though so i
feel pretty prepared okay
not really no i don't is there a part of
you because sometimes i think when dudes
come in here yeah just that competitive
nature is there a part of you that
thinks you maybe have a chance no of
course i think there's like this this
bigger part where like see that's what
i'm saying though there's even a part
well it's like when you see a what's
like when you're doing a hell gig and
every comic bombed and you're like i'll
turn it around but you know
but i know how to do stand-up i don't
even know how to do this so right what
is realistic he was like i just want to
score once and i was like sure okay
that's very possible yeah um yeah
because foosball's so it can be so
random too like somebody can just hit a
shot weird and it banks off and goes in
you can get lucky you can get lucky that
was the most condescending thing
could we could we score once anything
could happen
you know even a broken clock is wrong
twice a day whatever it is you man
i know this is the broken clock team
over here this is
all right if we if we school once i will
be happy i know that you're a pro i know
that you have you hustled people with
this before yes
really yeah we did a special episode
where i went undercover in vegas and i
hustled drunk dudes on the vegas strip
wow cause that's such a great
environment for it people are already
kind of looking to put money on stuff
and people are drunk and i just wore
like giant fake eyelashes had my tits
kinda out it was just like hi and i
pretended that i had a different web
series so i was like i have this web
series where i do things i've never done
before for the first time um it's called
pop my cherry
i didn't know that it's incredible
and dudes are just like what and i was
like i've never played foosball but we
found this table and then we'd get money
on the table and i would change uh
change my tune a little bit
that's the saddest reason to go broke in
vegas oh truly yeah all the reasons to
go like you like lose black all
right you lose pogo but losing just in
foozball yeah that's a that's a tough
one to explain to the wife the street
lady yeah
yep
so what is your experience coming into
this sam with foosball just classic in a
bar it's in a bar i've had a few in me
and it's so no real experience do you
usually spin
do i spin like like this you mean like
this like this guy
you know i don't
no i don't i don't i have no real
experience okay i just have to tell you
the rules are no spinning sometimes we
get people coming in here like maniacs i
get it okay that's the one time i've
ever scored on her is i spun it taylor
ripped it from the back and i knew
immediately cue the flashback
do whatever you have to do to score even
if it doesn't count
i will not cut to me just holding kelsey
down while he spins it just in a trunk
somewhere that's how you guys steal all
my trophies
my beloved trophies so also did you guys
have a strategy for why you are here i
think last time you were on you prefer
to be further away from the camera
because you talked about the size of my
head okay yeah
yes i would like to be further away same
taking photos with you
don't double my head closer you're just
a good seven feet back a good seven feet
back he'll take selfies of us sometimes
and he does it on purpose well he'll do
it down and with me in front oh it's
it's the meanest thing anyway disrespect
a lot of videos like i curl it around
just in here and she just goes no
yeah that's amazing but yeah she i think
her head's beautiful but uh you know
yeah what can you do
that was gross i'm sorry not that
out
we love to see it please continue again
this is what's so fun about having you
guys on together as a couple it's it's a
new thing to the show so yeah we're
gonna fight we're gonna we're gonna
exploit it a little bit amazing to you
unravels us what if this is all in
listen
you never listen that's why you didn't
spin it that way
this would get so many views then and i
would be so proud
we can go look yeah this is where it all
ended it's like comedian destroys
heckler but comedian destroys comedians
and relations yeah that's hey you take
us out
my ego couldn't handle it and be great
okay so we're gonna play one game to
five just to start get you guys a little
warmed up all right i'll get a little
warmed up too and um and then we'll play
a couple other rounds it'll be a good
time
you guys ready
yeah let me let me get let me get warmed
up here yeah yeah yeah get your berries
this is
you're you're holding them so tenderly
like this okay there you go okay
tighter grip there we have a good sex
life
that is the touch of a man who knows
that you can't just go crazy down there
don't go crazy all right he's actually
he's going to ask the handles for
consent
are you into this yellow guys okay okay
wait am i starting i'm getting i'm
letting you start
oh no i didn't mean to hit it you know
what i didn't mean to okay this was my
strategy last time i was just moving
really fast i am yeah taylor's okay you
get it you get it it didn't work at all
okay i passed it to sam that was on
purpose we're starting slippery oh
oh
you got it look at her passing it oh my
god
she is you are giving me this is like an
animal anxiety
yes taylor yeah
oh okay hold on what what
is that is it not leaving is that not
okay
is that all right taylor is technically
doing something illegal which is called
jarring so you can't hit the taste
oh my god you can't not hit the table
you can't hit the side so hard that it
moves the ball okay
okay although i would like to
continue seeing you do this is that good
yeah there you go if i hit the sides is
that bad you can hit the sides but just
not like over and over and over
it's like operation but you know what
so yeah
you got it taylor good job
okay
oh defense baby
oh
you know what i'm probably i don't like
how smugly you you threw that over right
there that was very that was it was like
a flick of the wrist
a little paprika on that
all right taylor you got this start us
off yeah okay
i absolutely don't got this no you have
this i believe it i got this on youtube
great special
we're just here to promote our various
projects here we go okay
all right okay that's that's jarring
that is you get it
oh that was even no
oh i'm sorry i'm really sorry no look
i'm a bad defender whenever you wanna
this is a team game i didn't know i was
gonna have to start it let's go okay
so okay i'm doing what you did you just
mentioned sam's special you got this sam
what is the newest one called
uh up on the roof and we got a little
documentary called full capacity up
there that's right about uh
the pandemic
and uh and the club's reopening in new
york mostly the comedy seller
okay
wow oh oh holy
it was close
that was like a sleep removed hey really
right put me in keep talking keep
talking to her talk to her about your
special you have other stuff
oh yes not in my house hell yeah mutombo
all right
oh shoot that's all right that's all
right
it's pretty good defensive stance yeah
oh
the noise it makes that's jarring it's
gonna haunt me that is charlie okay i'm
gonna wake up covered as well no
you got it you got this
we both believe i'm not sure i'm just
trying to be supportive
okay let's go i'm trying okay it's this
isn't cool it's in a spot come on
everyone can see this right okay it's
like trying to find the clitoris right
all right let's go we got this
we can get it
okay no
no
taylor's side i think we should skip
down we should switch sides
yeah also between points you guys can
switch and see if because i feel like i
might defend better
oh nice good d sam
oh i'm sorry that was my bad
sam is not doing too bad back here yeah
let's see
um i gotta get that out of there
okay so sam the recent one about clubs
opening back up i know what you're doing
as an interviewer and i don't care for
it well you know i also have to
i can't have there be
silence on
oh oh on the screen you got it you got
it
sam is really shutting me down in the
back yeah
and i'm not particularly enjoying it oh
that's okay
look you can get one let's get one do
you want to switch do you feel good
right here no i think you change it up
for the last point i defer to you
you got it
yeah
oh my god hard in my stomach okay so the
reason i was going to ask you
about the new special i'm not sure you
are not doing it
do that i was going to ask what
the worst shows you guys were doing
during the pandemic like was there one
that was particularly brutal like an
outdoor one or one stole the mic from me
in one show in like a backyard
a woman stole the mic from me it was her
backyard but she was charging people to
get in
and uh jesus yeah she sucked
i was so mad i wasn't recording that's
what made me oh right
those crowd work clips man
gold for instagram
and tay you didn't do too many
like
zoom things you did some outdoors
whitney and i went on tour
and then also i did a bunch in philly
okay
she's good
that's round one that's round one all
right okay
how are we feeling i think i feel like
warmed up my goal is to get a goal yeah
that is my goal is i'm i'm aiming low i
think we could do it yeah yeah i think
we could do that okay
that's right sam blocks me
i blocked you a couple of times yeah
yeah it's very nice it's very humble i
still feel like you guys are going to be
angry at me and at each other by the end
of this look it's building it's a slow
build
right now we're slightly irritated by
the end i'm going to be like i don't
like kelsey that much i don't know what
it is there's something about it your
friends are obnoxious i'm not getting
invited to the wedding someday
all right so come over here with me so
we're going to do some handicaps for
round two to try to make it i love it
okay but we have a handicap also
sometimes we're going to see we're going
to see we're already handicapped over
here
by our
lack of
experience we're just going to see let's
see what kind of fish get
this for us or you
okay so i got one pick and then you well
i mean it's all random anyway okay all
right
three three okay
so one we decided is that i
have to play with one hand
okay all right three three is that we
get another person you get it
of course
you start with three points
oh okay i like that yeah
lit up wow oh yeah i mean we're still
going to lose but now you know we're on
the board
here's the thing though she's giving us
charity yeah okay so i'm playing with
one hand you guys are starting with
three points but we're gonna play um
kind of like a game within a game where
i'm gonna be asking you guys questions
trying to see how well you know each
other oh okay and if you you really are
trying to bring us up if you don't both
know
the answer you lose a point
wow
okay so there's a couple ways to answer
the same thing yeah
but it's about one of us it's about it
so it'll be like
what is her favorite movie and then i'll
be what is your favorite you can't ask
favorite movie why because that's impo
well all right well i'm tough with that
that's tough you can't he doesn't have a
favorite movie
well i could you know what it i
think we could i think we could no but i
think you know what i would say your
favorite movie is okay right sure okay
yeah
look at my eyes are we going classic are
we going all the time are we going
we're going
modern
all right i think that you yeah yeah
all right
i've watched it can i give hints
no yeah hints are fair come on okay
i'm obsessed with movies yeah okay i
watched it without you
because you told me how much you liked
it really yeah yeah that's not the one
i'm thinking of oh what are you
thinking of
you watching without me yeah yeah i'm
giving you guys like three points okay
it was early on in our relationship and
you were like that's a great movie and i
was sick and i watched it by myself we
have not watched it together i don't
think this is these are too many hints
this is he's not getting i don't know
what it is okay i just you don't he
doesn't have a favorite movie so i'm
just trying to get us the same one that
he likes a lot
i do have a favorite movie so we can ask
mike i know hers okay but he doesn't
have one i know hers it's uh i'm gonna
go with uh singing in the rain hey
okay and what do you what is
i don't think i'm gonna get it what do
you have uh i was gonna say kiss kiss
okay
we keep our points
that's yeah okay good i watched it by
myself i thought we watched it i don't
know i watch it by myself
yeah classic oh my god youtube hell yeah
nice all right so you made it through
the first question let's play a point
and see what happens
yes
i just got it past one
oh
oh oh
she's lost a step i can feel it yeah oh
she's doing one hand that's what it is i
forgot about that i was feeling really
good about myself me too i forgot too
okay
his men are set up is making dude
hard
what am i doing
so river is just a dead ball like that
you can just pick it up and put it
damn it oh nice
oh
that was really good okay i'm gonna ask
you guys another one as we're playing
okay sure
um what would your death row meal be
like your last meal oh just like main
course that's super hard
well trying to get you guys to lose some
points here we've never talked about
that
we don't like to talk about that defense
is solid it's really good
really bothering me how many times i'm
having to shoot before i get a goal
why can't i no you know the man
oh finally
i'm gonna say death romeo type of food
chinese food yeah it's a good one yes
okay all right
and then what's sam what about tay i'm
gonna say i would say
like
san diego fish tacos would be my guess
not only did he get it he got
locations something
[Music]
big shout out to hellofresh with
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
you can skip trips to the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make cooking
at home easy fun and affordable that's
why it's america's number one meal kit
i've actually been using hellofresh for
years i'm obsessed with them the food is
amazing and being on the road so much i
love that the boxes just come right to
my door pre-portioned ingredients i have
to do so little to have seriously
amazing meals hellofresh helps out a ton
they cut back on meal prep and obviously
going to the grocery store so you can
spend less time in the kitchen and more
time with your friends and family and if
you're going to entertain they've got
you covered they've got charcuterie
boards and skinny dip dark chocolate
peppermint almonds hellofresh offers 50
menu and market items to choose from
every week including vegetarian calorie
smart and gourmet options so there's
always a ton of variety the new year is
a great time to focus on what's
important to you whether it's saving
money by ordering less take out learning
to cook or prioritizing your wellness
hellofresh is here to help with endless
options to make cooking at home simple
and enjoyable hellofresh cuts back on
time in the kitchen so you can spend it
on your other resolutions with meals
that are ready in around 30 minutes or
less plus with quick and easy meals
including 20 minute recipes and low prep
and easy clean up you can have an even
faster route to putting food on the
table hellofresh is 72 cheaper than a
restaurant meal of the same quality so
you can save on average over 65 dollars
per month when you order hellofresh
instead of grocery shopping that's more
money to put toward your other 2022
goals hellofresh also offers the
flexibility you need to easily customize
your order online or in your app i love
it because i can change my meals for
that week if i'm on the road i can skip
a week they make it so easy so go to
hellofresh.com fury16 and use code
fury16 for up to 16 free meals and three
free gifts that's hellofresh.com fury16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts hellofresh america's number one
meal kit
[Music]
that's pretty good that was really good
oh
i'm just trying to hit it i don't care
where you keep getting really close i
know and you already have three points
so
let's go
that was that was
that was a rough one
that that i felt okay next question for
you guys um
sam what is taylor's biggest pet peeve
oh
oh how much time do you have uh wait
wait wait wait wait all right she's
trying to unravel it let me see what
she's doing i don't know the answer to
it either so let me pick something
i mean because if he just guesses i
think i got it okay you you you just say
it
when i don't listen
yeah bad listening yeah
okay perfect yeah
and then uh taylor what is sam's biggest
pet peeve
for me
i was just thinking in general but how
how uh
overly anxious i am about everything
is that correct yeah yeah god you guys
are really really good we spend a lot of
time together quarantine
quarantine
yeah after about three months of
quarantine you just start going if you
were gonna die what would you eat
that's all that's left to talk about
yeah yeah okay you got a favorite color
[Laughter]
sam what is taylor's worst habit
i mean these are these are straight up
just
the worst that's like the same as the
other one yeah
i was going to say is anxiety a habit or
not no no
it's a disorder and there is help
better health wwe
yeah i don't know if kayla has like
really bad habits i think those are the
same answer you think some of us yeah i
don't i don't think
okay oh wait i know his worst bad habit
biting your nails yeah that's true okay
oh my god
but yeah i don't really have any picking
apart that defense sam trying
all right let's go okay all right okay
score at least one here um oh yeah okay
i'll start now
thank you so much coach
uh that's a dead ball right yeah so it's
gonna go back to you i don't know um
favorite porn category no i'm kidding
i am going to ask dan soder mine's easy
okay
oh yeah would you guys answer that it's
men who listen
that's her porn category the guy was
like what was that
oh give me more details you're right i
haven't what i said earlier wasn't okay
oh
um how about we both have jokes about
porn so it wouldn't be fair what about
love language oh i mean
that's you're supposed to have all of
them that's that's
yeah that's a sam no do you know
i think cause didn't we talk about that
on self helpless that it was like some
pastor
some pastor oh
yeah the love language is harder
your spirit is just deflated yeah you
blocked me
way too many times you're doing really
well
it's upsetting all right great job
okay guys so now we're gonna play the
final round which is where we play two
ball
oh my god taylor's familiar with this
yeah so there are two balls
on the table you have to score both to
get a point if we each score one it's a
wash okay okay so first of five wins
here's the thing
if you guys lose
you have to do a blindfolded food
challenge with each other oh come on
where
you each feed each other three things
and try to guess what is being fed okay
i was mindful of your dietary
restrictions thank you you're welcome
i miss you i love you gluten-free food
challenge it's gonna be fine
wait can you have gluten
no i can okay okay i didn't know dairy
this is the safest space ever for
this is like fear factor like no is this
okay one of my best friends so it's like
i have to just know with my eyes closed
so i feel like we're halfway there okay
okay you guys ready for that yeah i'm
ready yeah okay let's go let's go
anti-lance armstrong let's go two ball
that will forever be the name of the
third round is armstrong around yeah or
the answer
okay one two two three go
oh oh
oh i was backing her for a minute i'm
sorry i got them both too
oh my god
oh jeez
just yeah yes yes
oh i almost had it it really did
oh
get her taylor let's do this are you
guys still feeling satisfied with oh
taylor bean up front and sambita i think
honestly i think it's our best shot all
right
she's showing promise all right
the way you said it right before you
scored are you guys still good here and
then come on are you still confident and
being in the back
all right okay i tried you're doing
you're doing way better than i thought
either of us would do okay go
oh you got on you're good job oh oh
yes oh my god
oh wait we have to get both
okay
all right so it doesn't wash let's
switch let's give it like okay let's
let's give her a run for our money here
okay why these are all warm
really good really sweet really clean
hands okay
[Applause]
okay
oh what am i gonna do yeah yeah stay up
there stand up there
oh oh
no no no no no good job thank you
no no no no no no no no oh
no
no don't do it like that what do i do
yeah no yeah
that was a good day that was a good day
no i almost spawned that i know i'm
sorry it's okay you're doing great thank
you you've learned so much since last
time today thank you
let's do this
all right i i say we give this this spot
another yeah yeah for sure first mix it
up okay okay
one two three go
that was i didn't even even see what
happened
that wasn't i didn't even hear start
i didn't hear it
you stay in the holes right get it get
it get it
it's all right we'll get that you put me
down here okay but you're doing great
you just do what you're doing you try to
get in right here right in the holes
is this the first time
oh my god i did it i did it
over here
oh oh oh
there you go there's the first time you
guys have played a sport together uh yes
oh we shot we shot
i almost said basketball hoops around
that one time
oh cause sam you're a big sports guy i
like sports yeah yeah and i'm okay i was
in marching band so much oh sure oh it's
a good value
all right
it's okay i'm
i believe in this round this is where we
turn it around
jesus
okay okay guys
oh okay all right one two four yes
i got one on him you did you did get one
that that came on another one that's all
he wanted let's clip that up for the
gram right there
that's perfect
that's the only reason he came right one
oh okay okay
yes
oh
yes good job
oh i almost had no no no no no taylor
and i are both anxious people and
chewball is
not good for anxiety i'm trying i'm
trying i'm trying i can't that's a death
good job oh you almost had it
no there we go there we go they're both
down there
okay
i'm breathing like i'm in labor this is
oh shoot oh good job yes okay
oh my god
oh my god if i could hit both of these
at the same time
good job
no
sorry that wasn't a clean goal
okay taylor
you're doing good today don't get don't
panic just block for the love
that's right you're in her head taylor
yeah look at that
that's when you talk it makes me panic
all right we give us one more it was one
more because we could take this i don't
want to anymore i don't want him anymore
no it's okay we can
okay
is that it
the foosball portion is over okay you
guys did it i thought that was i did it
we scored it we always we both scored
yeah we did
right you can walk away with your head
held high yeah yeah
kind of kind of
how do you feel do you feel like it
brought you guys together yeah i'm
surprised we knew all those answers that
was pretty good that was nice right
right yeah yeah that was great let's
remember this good job the newlywed game
would have creamed you
we got we got those right yeah we did
pretty good that's pretty good yeah
hold on to this good feeling in this
good time because bad things are about
to happen
is it gross food i don't know oh i don't
know taylor i don't know
who cares let's live a little all right
um
so sam you're going to be feeding taylor
food first am i blindfolded as well or
no no no just me
too all right
this feels
i can feel the same but
all right
some nurses and doctors get kinky when
they work
all right so i recommend putting this on
this i've already done this and i think
i'm not worried about this taylor okay
good so should i show what we're doing
while i do it yeah a little bit of this
look it i'm going to say this it
shouldn't go together but it does kind
of like us yeah see
look at that
that's a point oh i think i have to oh
there might be a little label thing
sorry yeah a label
okay hold on
you're not going to get it detective all
right
let's do this
okay oh i'm excited for you to try to
guess these three things okay
yeah really getting it tell me when to
really get it because i'm not just going
to leave it open open your mouth for the
internet to put dicks inside it okay
ready yeah
it's pretty good i think i've had this
before there's mustard on my mom oh
jesus crushing it
i've i've done this and it's actually
pretty good
wow i was really hoping for that to be
more disgusting this one is just more
unsettling i think we should end on this
i've been on trip talk okay okay i'm
doing all kinds of on so this one
next yeah all right
i don't think she's gonna love these but
she's not gonna hate him okay okay just
by knowing her
okay
i'm just going to let you guys know
right now i was kinder to you tay in the
food selection than i was with you sam
just because i helped i want to know
what oh am i still going oh you're going
awesome okay all right
okay this looks like you're feeding her
on a farm
all right yeah
the internet's still gonna edit dicks in
your mouth i know there's not there's no
way to avoid that oh this is um
well there's like kale chips
yeah what flavor though
oh
cool ranch whoa
was it wait with a c or a k
which one
look i had very bad eyesight for a long
time before i got lasik my other senses
are razor sharp
okay
is there another one or am i done one
more one more i think you're gonna like
this one best just by knowing you but
maybe i'm wrong can i get an ice pop to
suck on cleanse the palette
i can get video i'm getting i'm right
i'm kidding
all right
this is one of those things that i feel
like
is maybe only in austin so it's like a
weird oh okay this isn't edible here no
okay oh my god but you're still gonna
put it in my mouth yep what no no no no
no
ready yeah yeah so i forgot your
blindfolded uh-huh
oh boy you're just giving her
that giant oh my god okay i mean
that's a gummy something yeah
i don't know what it's called it's like
a
second it's like some sort of twizzler
i don't think one driver's like there's
anyway yeah there's no way no way you're
getting a jellyfish
no but getting gummies is it
yeah you you got the majority it's you
want to look at what it is
you can take the blindfold off a mini
gummy taco is what it is oh okay yeah
they're pretty good
you know what this showed is a lot of
trust between the two of you oh yeah and
maybe some trust in me that i wasn't
gonna ruin your whole day but like
you didn't
you were so
calm yeah yeah it's a terrifying thing
of all the food in the world that you
could put something in somebody's mouth
and i trust everyone in this room
i dressed it was really bad i'm not
going to feed it to her you know neither
are you yeah you said i thought about
your dietary restrictions before we
started that's true what a good friend
sam is not going to be as
this will be fine lucky here we go okay
so sam get blindfolded what if it just
got really dark and she's like a dead
rat
you said you love new york
[Laughter]
thank you all right sam keep those eyes
closed i mean they're they're closed oh
okay oh okay
is this
is this going to hurt
do we know how bad this is is this going
to hurt
what is it what kind of question is that
i just razor blades
is the best question you could have ever
asked is this going to be
his reaction to be like what the
jesus i don't think so i'll tell him to
have a small bite
i'm sure it's okay can i get the context
of hurt
i mean what hole are we putting this in
should i tell them can i say that part
what just this part
no okay sorry
all right i think it'll be okay are we
starting what are we starting up maybe
we should end with that
whatever you want to do
okay
this i have
this i've bought for you before oh
really
i don't know if you'll remember and i
didn't get
well i can't be telling i can't be
saying examples no
it's just such an unfortunate you've
bought it for me i mean you can also
that smells good you can smell it okay
ready
open up
okay
there you go
i'm gonna say
it's some type of jerky
i'm going to guess
i'm going to guess it's like a turkey
jerky
is that is that off it doesn't taste
that good close
vegan jerky
that's great okay this one is
oh this is the one i was excited about
okay uh-oh yeah this is you know
it's not gonna hurt you
all right
all right ready
what do you think
just silent
i mean it's a type of condiment
[Music]
this is describe the flavor
can i give hints hold on i just want to
hear what he thinks that flavor is okay
yeah what do you think the flavor is i'm
gonna guess ky jelly
with like a scent of strawberry you're
in the same you're in the same theater
yeah i think we would feed you
like just a straight-up shot of lube i
mean i guess it is some of them are
edible yeah that's true what what what
what about
that it's uh
what do you
let me see if you get it based off this
when i don't eat breakfast and i give
you an excuse as to why i don't
think about why
because you just had like oat milk or
something uh-huh um what do i say and
you're like that's not food
yeah i say that's not food and then what
happens
and then you complain about something
else no no
what's my retort to that's not food
i don't know what is it really maybe he
should have one more bite okay i'm
trying to help
oh it looks i say it all the time
glad this wasn't the question earlier i
don't know what is it
i guess it's baby food oh okay prune
baby food yeah i mean i'm not on my not
on my list of foods that i eat
that's the point no good morning i say i
had i had matcha or i had
something you're like that's not food
and i say oh milk is food and he said no
it's not and i say babies eat it
yeah i don't remember you saying that
are you serious i've said that so many
times see it doesn't listen to me that's
what we're talking about
i thought that was like a bit i thought
that was a classic sam and taylor bit no
recollection we well i don't feel bad
about serving this next one now at least
we're unraveling while i'm eating crappy
food
we'll get a good dinner later and we'll
really get into it this is the uh
this is the the closer this one this is
the big finisher okay just take a little
bite of this one
over like
okay take your pants off
all right ready
okay
there it is
spicy pickle there you go damn i was
just scared i'm a jew you think you're
going to trick me on a spicy pickle why
don't you serve me a lot connects around
let's dance
i did not think of that aspect of it and
you're right you can take that off oh my
god smoked salmon what's that next i
mean come on
take them off all right
oh man i was just scared it was gonna be
too hot
but it was okay that's why she was
asking would it hurt yeah yeah no i
think we're okay i was
somewhat close not even close at all i
was trying to help you with the baby
food one yeah i should have thought i
didn't
i didn't go wide enough no guesses we
got some weird the gummy taco i
would guess baby food right away for a
taste test with your eyes closed yeah
baby food kidding me you guessed lube
before baby food you're degenerate well
i don't know i feel like you know
look we're not having kids you guys have
been the absolute best to have on so
please plug where people can find you
your specials all of the good stuff
absolutely teach homecomedy.com
i'm on tour
and uh quarter life crisis on netflix
yes baby um yeah samurail.com
shows tour
a bunch of specials on youtube check
them out
both incredible comedians great comedy
couple we'd love to see it
uh you can follow me on tiktog and
instagram kelseacookcomedy my tour dates
are at kelseycook.com and please go
subscribe to the all things comedy
youtube channel so you can keep seeing
other upcoming episodes of risk of fury
all right we will see you guys next time
[Music]
you